So in a previous lesson we created a class
called movie. Now this class had the following attributes,
the movie's title, its storyline, a link to the
movie's poster image, and a link to its YouTube
trailer. Now in addition to these things, the class
movie also had a function called show_trailer. After we
had defined this class movie we created several instances
of this class. Instances like Toy Story and Avatar.
Now further imagine that we wanted to create
another class called TvShow. I would think that
this class would have details like the title
of the show, its season and episode number. And
also, the TV station that this show is
aired on. Additionally, this class could also have
a function called, get_local_listings. Once we've created a
class called TvShow, we can create multiple instances of
this class, instances like, season one, episode one
of Breaking Bad, and the final episode of Seinfeld.
Alright, so if we continue our thought experiment
here, we can further imagine that there can be
several items that both of these classes can
share amongst each other. Things like title for sure,
also things like duration of the movie and
duration of the TV show in minutes. So the
best way to structure this code would be
to create another class called Video, which would
have two attributes. The video's title, and the
video's duration. And the class Movie, could inherit from
this class Video. To do this, we would
have to add the class name Video, inside these
parentheses. Now, this would mean that class Movie,
would inherit title and duration, from class Video. Additionally,
the class TvShow could also inherit from class
Video. To do this we would also have
to add the class name Video inside these
parentheses. Now this would mean that class TvShow would
inherit title and duration from class video. Now
you can clearly see how we can write a
piece of code. In this case, class Video,
and continue to reuse it in multiple different places.
Another big benefit of writing code this way,
in addition to just reusing code, is that
it allows us to follow an intuitive model
of how things exist in our brain. So intuitively
speaking, we know what videos are, we also know what TV shows and movies are. So
writing code in this way allows programmers to
map how things exist in our brain onto code.